así después una decisión que ha dado
bastante que hablar fue una propuesta en
realidad de el alcalde de esa ciudad un
alcalde que es un ecologista y pues es
más una decisión acerca de cuáles son
los tipos de de trajes de baño de
vestidos de baño que se pueden utilizar
en las piscinas municipales del grupo de
nobles y pues hubo un voto el día de
ayer del consejo de esa ciudad un voto
bastante apretado 29 personas a favor 27
en contra y de hecho varios
manifestantes frente al edificio donde
estaban aún votando pidiendo que no se
aprobara esta propuesta porque iba en
contra después de todos los principios
de laicidad de la país sin embargo pues
finalmente pues se aprueba esto que
permite el uso de un traje de baño que
cubra desde la cabeza hasta los pies en
este caso es el burkini que muchas
mujeres de confesión musulmana usan pero
no todas pero también algo de lo que no
se habla tanto es que dentro de este
proyecto también pues se abre la
posibilidad que las mujeres que lo
desean pues puedan estar topless en la
piscina es decir que puedan tener los
senos al aire libre así que vamos a ver
esta propuesta que de hecho entra en
vigor el próximo primero de junio va a
mostrar tal vez unas imágenes bastante
contrastantes allá en las piscinas
municipales de guano